oh man I love this why are trumps
accused co-conspirators smiling in their
mug shots a booking photo normally
reflects gravity bewilderment and even
surprise that's not the case with some
of the former president's co-defendants
Jenna Ellis and David Shaffer in their
mugshots in Georgia I saw this and I
started thinking about it all the
defendants they seem to be having a
pretty good time you know I don't know
about this these are other people you
know but uh I think the answer is it
also uh goes into why they all just
surrendered without question
they've there's a strategy that we don't
know they see something coming they are
extremely confident that this is not
going to go the way the Democrats plan
it to go and that's why they're laughing
about it I don't know exactly what that
is I know that we got uh we have Trump's
mug shot Donald Trump posted his first
tweet in two and a half years on his
first acts formerly Twitter and it's his
mug shot and he's selling merch if you
go to his website and scroll down I
think they have it legendary
absolutely look at this yeah Never
Surrender mug mug shot
[Laughter]
it's kind of surreal because there's
like one of the things that I love to
watch they make these AI videos of trump
in jail singing songs with Joe Biden and
Barack Obama and now I'm seeing the
actual mugshot I think the mugshots
better than the AI pictures of him
that's crazy though hey you smart though
yeah Mrs man put to the heart more merch
but um if I was these people I would
have smiled like the Defiance for being
having a photo that bad taken of you
with like the really bad lighting inside
you know it's like there's like a flash
on the camera while the room is already
overly lit just to just laugh in their
face right it's an active Defiance so I
love how fast they got this up too it's
like he tweeted this very quickly after
he left the Georgia jail the image comes
up and he's already got t-shirts for
sale to be fair everybody did what we
did over at Tim Cass is we we made the
Revenge poster where it looks like the
Obama hope poster but it's Trump's mug
shot looking all vicious and it says
Revenge yeah I just want to say to
anybody who sees that graphic that the
one that we made free to use and
distribute we we it's free for public
use we have asserted that I don't want
to own that image I want everyone to use
that image but we did put up a shirt for
sale I just want to make sure everyone
realizes you can take that and make your
own shirt you don't gotta buy from us
some people just don't feel like it they
wanted to buy a shirt I'll take it but
you can take that image and do whatever
you want with it wow nice
it's funny because everyone on Instagram
is now posting that as their profile
picture yeah on Instagram yeah it's
legendary yeah honestly and it's the
first thing that Democrats and
Republicans have agreed on in like years
because everyone loves the photo the
Democrats love it because they hate him
the Republicans in the in the populists
love it because they love him yeah and
they they understand that it's him in an
active Defiance yeah he's going to go up
in the polls after this he's gone gone
up in the polls every single time he got
indicted so but I'm just kidding so a
former president could be accused of
this and actually possibly go to jail
that's crazy bro it is wild this is
America right I mean it is wild I mean
it's been a Witch Hunt I mean from Alvin
Bragg up in New York all the way to Jack
Smith uh down in you know dating him
down in Florida and then in New York and
then now here in Georgia with this
ridiculous RICO case
um and then the fact that they went
ahead and indicted Rudy Giuliani as well
who is what I would call the father of
the RICO it's it's crazy look at Trump's
prediction uh Trump's movement in the
prediction Market his indictment made
him go up three cents so if you look at
the 30 day you can see that he like dips
down a little bit and then he spikes
back up 50 57 58 61. I don't know about
polls whatever all I can tell you is
that Donald Trump
the prediction Market believes he will
be the Republican Presidential nominee
yeah and they believe it more so that
he's been indicted and a mug shot came
out
this is this is what I'm curious about
what does it say about the state of this
country that both Democrats and
Republicans are utilized are celebrating
this as a fundraising ticket as a
merchandising opportunity you know there
are there are people on the left making
merch of his mug shot saying like you
know criticizing him then there's
conservatives posting the same mug the
mug shot on mugs and shirts saying
Justice Revenge Etc everybody likes the
photo for different reasons yeah my
concern is
what's the next step what's if if we're
all here at this level
what's love what's the next level Donald
Trump actually goes to jail and then you
get the right fund Rising off and being
in jail and the left fundraising of him
being in jail and then what comes after
that what comes after that they're not
stopping it just keeps getting crazier
Secret Service stay with him if he goes
to jail yes they so they have to stay in
jail with him yep so I've done I've done
Secret Service details before
um I protected a president of a foreign
country out in Africa one time and ours
well I'm sorry one of our presidents no
no foreign country because it was the
U.N yeah a foreign president because so
so what ends up happening right so HSI
is under DHS alongside Secret Service so
whenever you have the UN meetings it's
typically in September um at least when
I was on the job but
they don't have the manpower to cover
everybody so they you know they augment
it with getting HSI agents in to help
them out as well so you know they're
pretty thorough with their you know with
their details and stuff like that and as
far as like the president goes I don't
know how they would actually be able to
incarcerate them like everyone that sees
them you have to have a you know a site
survey a week or two prior wow so I
don't know how they would be able to
actually jail them I mean the only way I
could think of them actually putting him
in some type of incarceration is huge
they would maybe have to build another
facility for him maybe they'd have to
put them on house arrests house arrest
for yeah it would have to be house
arrest because it would be a nightmare a
logistical nightmare for the Secret
Service to protect him while he's in
jail so of course he'd have to be
isolated but then all the prison guards
are coming the food that comes into him
they can't put him on house arrest in
Georgia he didn't live there
maybe you could get a residence there I
don't know but I mean what is it like if
Trump is convicted in Georgia they have
to put him in jail he went to the jail
already he wrote about he complained
about he said it was awful if they say
okay fine we get it we'd have to shut
down an entire wing of the prison just
for Trump Secret Service and all of that
stuff so we're gonna put him on house
arrest what do they do make him buy a
house
offer him hey if you buy a house you get
house arrest otherwise you're going to
jail Dan bongino said Trump should just
not pay not post bond and force them to
figure out what the they're gonna do
oh cause he's a former secret service
agent yeah yep yeah he said Federal
supremacy clause they could just shut
down the whole prison what are they
going to do about it
you know what if he didn't post a bond
that would cause a logistical nightmare
for them that would actually wow it's
actually pretty smart I got I got it but
he knows that because he's former Secret
Service so he knows the nightmare it is
to protect the president United States
if it were me wow I'm not Trump and you
can tell me that I'm wrong about this
and Trump's doing the right thing I'm
not saying that I'm right about it I'm
just telling you how I feel if I how old
is Trump 76 77 77 78 78 77 right I think
he's 77. nobody knows nobody knows let
me uh let me let me let me I I because
when he went to court in DC I think for
his age yeah yeah because they said he
would be the same age uh yeah Biden was
when he runs if he wins for the second
term if I was 77 and I was in Trump's
position
dude it's balls to the wall you guys
ever watch Little Miss Sunshine that
movie I think it's that movie you've
seen it Kellen yeah is that the one
where the grandfather is doing heroin
oh I think it's been a while it might be
I could be wrong could be a different
movie I'm thinking of but basically it's
like this really old guy and they find
out that he's doing heroin and they're
like what is wrong with you he's like
I'm 80 years old
if I was 77 I'd be like lock me up I
don't care I'm gonna lay down and then
you get to deal with all of the world's
problems yeah I get it Trump's I'm not
Trump Trump's not me but I I I'm 37 I'm
at the point where I just bli let me
sleep like you if I don't post a bond
you're telling me I get a few months off
I'm just gonna lay down and go to bed
whatever dude that's not wired that way
right he's not wired yeah and he's got a
campaign yeah but that would be a
logistical nightmare for them in Atlanta
yeah but I think it helps them in the
long run a lot of people said it's hard
to campaign but think about the chaos
the Democrats would cause if they
actually remanded him yeah I'd let him
I'd say this they come in fonte we're
going to negotiate your terms of
surrender and I'll be like I refuse to
post any bond at all
I was at the outright and they would
have been like then we're gonna arrange
it do it
have fun I know what they'd say no bail
and then I would come out afterwards and
be like if they thought the charges were
real why didn't they post why didn't
they uh require bail you know what they
would fold they'll just release him on
his personal recognizance and that's
what they would do but that's what I'm
saying
if if in the negotiations Trump said
I will not post bond period if you
impose it
they would have said okay then
recognizance right yeah no bail and then
okay deal then I would have walked out
of the prison out of the jail and just
said if these charges were serious
wouldn't they have tried to require bail
or remand they didn't even do it they
told me I'm free to go because they're
unserious people yeah so either way you
get the winning PR move out of it yes
that's like a circus man that's awesome
but but in this Trump just said I'll pay
whatever and so all that really happens
now is they get their Narrative of trump
as a criminal out on bond yeah I think
they for him he's like I got a campaign
I got a campaign I got to get back out
there and let the people know bro
sometimes you've you've got to be the
one being you have to be more aggressive
to put the pressure
on the on on the other player right you
know what I know people don't care for
the poker analogies but we were just
playing earlier yeah and we were given
you know we're teaching you guys the
basics of it but you can have the losing
hand but if you're more aggressive your
opponent s so you might be thinking
Trump could be thinking if they arrest
me I'm in trouble because I'm not gonna
be able to campaign and I think I'll
lose
try a bluff Trump then says arrest me I
dare you how scared are you and they're
gonna say no no we won't do it even
though it may actually screw Trump over
they might be too scared they might just
say okay you're free to go and then
Trump gets the pr play out of it so
you're saying Go full Breaking Bad
Walter White just go with it wrong with
it and just head for the hill I'm just
saying if I was 77. if I was 77 I would
just be like there is nothing you can
say or do I am old I'm gonna die anyway
guys he can't do that he has to he has
to push back into the people he's he's
Petty with the people who who slide him
yeah I do like the idea however of like
him trying to like scrounge a phone in
prison to send out tweets
every every update is from like a from
like a black market found that he has to
get from an inmate yeah like that have
been hilarious but no I mean these are
absolutely um you know no pun intended
trumped up charges on him right and I
think this is a political play from uh
funny Willis or Fannie Willis whatever
they want to call her
um I mean she did this with the YSL case
she wants to do a big press release I
mean they died in him at night she's
been trying to push for this thing for a
while and you know are all the charges
gonna stick probably not but it sounds
sexy to say oh we got a RICO case thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time